The joe rogan experience.
Do you being famous?
Do you compare it to not being famous very much anymore?
Um,
meaning like do you go like fuck,
do you want today to go fuck,
I wish I could just,
I wish it were 1990 I wish I had the identity of 1990 no,
you know how I look at it,
it's just a bunch of people being nice for the most part.
It's like what are you putting out there?
How I have opinions about things and I joke around about things like the last
bad energy that I got was when I was making fun of some dude in the country
music awards,
but homeboy was standing in front of a jet plane,
a country music song with jeans that had like cut rips on them,
like on purpose,
like all over them.
And I was like,
come on,
that's,
that's fucking ridiculous there.
Right?
You were none of them on a,
on Twitter.
I couldn't stop goofing on him goofing on those genes and that.
I was even admitted that I wear a fanny pack and I have a wallet chain and I'm
still goofing on that.
Like that's the stupidest fucking jeans were like one day we're going to look
back at those genes.
This is country music,
man.
Country Music is supposed to be Merle haggard,
Johnny Cash.
And you know that that's like real country music.
This is like,
this is not,
that's not real country.
You're standing in front of a jet.
The fuck are you doing in front of a jet?
What are you doing like in a hanger?
Like he's playing overseas,
like mere for overseas with the boys I'm getting from the Jetta supports troops.
Oh,
like an f 15 and something.
Exactly.
And it's like what?
What are you doing there?
I don't know if the whole show was in front of a jet.
They might've done the whole country music awards in front of a jet,
which would have been awesome.
I don't know if the sets changed,
you know?
I really have no idea.
I only watched it for a little bit,
but it was,
I made a joke that country music awards hates black people so much.
They won't even use black microphones cause it was a red microphone,
a lawyer.
I was like,
it was last time you saw a red microphone.
Funny Cause I will shit on stuff online and I'm like,
well am I at a certain like we're comics and then a certain point it's like
Wendy and go,
I don't,
I don't want to make fun of that or I don't know.
It's hard man.
Because I always want to say what's funny and what I would say amongst my
friends who wouldn't judge me like that,
that we could all be talking like,
like per perfect example,
Amy Schumer,
when Amy Schumer's on yesterday and we were talking to her,
we were,
we were joking around about her mother possibly being a cunt.
And I'm like,
how often do you,
are you,
you know,
you could just always go there when you're with a bunch of comics,
you're all just sitting around shit on each other.
You could always go to some terrible place and we don't really think you mean
it.
I'm not going to call you on it.
I know you're just trying to be funny,
but saying something fucked up.
That's,
yeah,
that's like with the,
we talked about the n word last time,
but I was,
I was thinking about how comics,
I was thinking today how my brother Kevin Comedian,
Kevin Brennan and a tell when I was like in high school had a joke where if they
would like be on the phone and they go like,
hey,
what's the weather like?
And he'd be like,
terrain and that'd be like fucking daggers.
But somehow the blast,
I remote control the weather.
Oh and Hilarious,
right?
No,
of course you don't mean it.
And also the ID,
you're making fun of the idea that most people just don't,
and that's how I got hired.
They just don't get hired and they won't,
they're not able to look at life with layers.
Right.
And they can't see that at the bottom of it.
It's supposed to be about intent,
you know,
and this is,
this is not just about white guys that are throwing nay.
Yeah,
no,
it's just like,
or like you'll just go like water.
Cont yeah,
you got to know when someone is joking,
when it's obvious there's,
I mean there's certain people,
but some people will say things in a crowd and like,
you'll be the only one that laughs and there'll be like eight or nine people
that are really pissed off.
Come on.
He said something like Gilbert with the,
with the,
with the Geico ads and all the Gilbert's jokes about the tsunami.
We're fucking hilarious.
They were like,
oh,
that was as he was fought by,
I was watching them in real time going like,
boy,
these are fucking funny.
And then he'd gotten in trouble.
Oh,
well he went too quick,
too quick.
You couldn't even do that now.
You can't do tsunami too soon.
But they,
if you couldn't do it now,
because people don't remember it.